when i think of education in general um
both school and university level because
a lot of this stuff can filter down to
schools as well is i think okay what are
the things that no matter if you're an
adult you're going to have to deal with
these things
right no matter what you choose to do
how you live your life there's certain
things that we all have to deal with
that's why i brought up health health
and nutrition right we all we all have a
body we all eat food multiple times per
day and we've got one body that we need
to take care of right so
to me it's ludicrous that someone can go
through a
multi-decade education process and you
don't learn at least the basics of
taking care of your body that's insane
right money
we all deal with money whatever job you
do however you live your life whether
you stay single you get married have
children
you're gonna have to deal with money
you're gonna have to deal with money and
with finances
gaping hole like there's that's not even
a subject